did you start having second thoughts
below the terms are like I need to step
off this project it will not give you
the confidence to say you know what
these kids can do this they can pull it
off I'm going to stick I saw they showed
you know they showed me a you know
footage and they did a lot of work on
the look of the movie and the look is
obviously gorgeous and really you know
beautiful and and I was I you know I
have I get into arguments with directors
all the time so it's not really you know
I wasn't it was no different with
correct Kent he said that you hadn't
seen I haven't seen the movie at all no
no no no how do you feel that I see if
we thought Taylor Danny are fantastic I
mean just everybody it's really good I'm
just I to really damn fine film I thank
you thank you cool I'm the core like the
script that I thought that we were going
to have but then of that like I said
first time director allow scenes didn't
work out so then when you cut those out
then the plot just of like Swiss cheese
like you can see it but it's not fold
and then we had to do some reshoots so
it's kind of like rethinking things and
trying to compress you know like we had
a scene and say it didn't work but we
really needed that scene it would like
be rewriting it so the rewriting kind of
continued all the way through to the end
of like second unit so like two years
total
happy so happy how did you how did this
get in front of you and I was about that
I just I new kitten through friend Elena
who played the blonde girl with pigtails
and she just somehow got in connected
with him I I was just a little christus
in Alabama and somehow I thank you thank
you so much thank you and for our son
sound guy yep so you're part of the
three-person team no no I did post
production oh you'd also even post
production yep impressive Kurt is the
whole post production team like at the
kirk is gonna be like so much really
good job yeah good job terrific job so
are you are you are you working with the
composer's can you tell us a little bit
about your process behind the scenes
sure um I got connected with kenton
through a friend of mine James Lunsford
he was and one of the nicest guys that
I've ever ever known and he got me
connected with this project through see
you guys met him only good film forum
Craig what's up craigslist and don't and
so basically we had worked out this
entire process of working of the
internet breaking up the film into
something like 12 pieces to about 12
pieces and doing chunk by chunk and
sending it back over for reviews and
notes and such and then kitten ended up
coming over to my place drove up from
drove to two miles in Tennessee and
stated with us for two weeks and slept
on our couch and everything we mix the
thing in in my living room and and that
was pretty much it that's pretty much it
and I had to
to assistant editors Ralph Guzman and
Auggie Restivo both one was in Mexico
another was in at the time I think
Florida and managed them over over ftp
on the internet as well and then just
kind of formed it after that moments
where he seems truly disturbing and
there are moments in there other moments
where he seems like the nicest guy in
the world we talked a lot about that
actually you really wanted ken really
wanted me to be a nice guy just because
somebody doesn't have his functioning
like it exactly properly doesn't mean
they wouldn't be nice so that was an
element that we talked about a lot
because and and tried to you know make
make happen in some of the some of the
things but you know and then so he just
said he he had an example of someone he
you know kind of knew like this who do
um was a nice guy and you know and then
was a complete you know the lunatic on
the um you know other times and I think
that's probably possibly very accurate
with the number of people who are in
that kind of situation so that's just we
played on that oh yeah I mean I I there
are certain things that I see that you
know i'm not i don't really think a lot
about certain things by I mean I try and
more inhabit the character rather than
think it through that much but I find
that looking there are certain things
that I was doing that I had no idea that
you know
they're the walk there's certain things
about them his walk that I just didn't
you know the sort of something very
specific it was going on that I really
did just this part of what happened with
that guy and they sort of related to the
pig missing piece somehow it feels like
you know uh this is the paper and write
things down all the time just take stuff
my own life or whatever so then when you
right there was yes there was the
gimmick but then like all the lot of the
dialogue and stuff comes from either
your subconscious or notes that I've
written things from my life or whatever
so it was like taking the gimmick and
that's the outline and then you fill it
in with like normal stuff was the
approach gun I had a question about the
paintings and the origins of each of the
imagery that you put in did you start
off with that and then recreate it on
film as it is in the in the movie or did
you kind of see what you had available
on set and then make the paintings based
on that that was a really complicated
problem to figure out uh because we had
like we didn't have a location scout and
we're like trying to find awesome cool
locations and then get all these people
to paint these paintings and their free
time and so it was guessing like I did
scat location scouting through like
books at the library in the Google Earth
and then I was like okay guys this is
kind of the texture we want to go for or
something and so then two of my friends
from home one of them was an awesome
artist who I knew from the movie theater
she just had these sketches all time I
was like can you do this so she made all
the small paintings and then my other
friend from high school who had seen his
drawings he did the big murals he spent
like a week at our house making the
murals yes it was kind of tricky it was
like also because I guess we hit that we
had the paintings first before we ever
went to the locations so we kinda had to
like I don't know but then like I said
there's plot holes so when he opens the
little curtain things and
the big ones those were an afterthought
like we were like oh the story is not
clear enough like we need to add
something in so like the poison thing
was to hone in like the poison aspect or
the whatever and the other one
originally he had painted a car
exploding and the painting but then we
went to the landfill to location scout
there was a boat on top with this like
landfill and the guy who took me around
the landfill managers name is tadpole
and so I'm driving around with tadpole
and there's this boat in the middle of
nowhere and I'm like tadpole can we blow
this up like I'll have to ask bossman
about it but I think that would be a
problem so you know there we had a boat
to blow up and didn't have to get car so
then we just painted the boat and stuck
it on and then also to further like the
the words on top of the small paintings
were an afterthought to because I
thought that if we just threw all those
words on there maybe when you're
watching it you're like okay they
thought this through or something